all right let's start with some
international news today I was not
initially going to talk about this today
but I got emails about it over the
weekend and read a bunch of Articles
this morning and there's really like a
bigger story here in what's going on in
Europe globally uh or the impact of uh
the global impact of what we start to
see in Europe and Germany you know we've
had this
um uh back story ever since the election
of Donald Trump about German Chancellor
Angela Merkel becoming effectively the
leader of the Free World now as many uh
as I should mention every time I talk
about this that's not an actual position
it's sort of a colloquial designation
often assigned to the president of the
United States When Donald Trump was
elected it was so humiliating he was so
pathetic that the consensus we could say
uh plurality of the consensus was that
Angela Merkel had become the leader of
the Free World long-standing German
Chancellor we then more recently learned
that she would not be up for re-election
um and we now are sort of looking to
Germany in a sense as a referendum on
this authoritarian rightward shift that
we've seen in much of Europe and around
the world of course in places like
Hungary and others in Europe but also
the duterte style stuff Putin
um uh as well as
um you know bolsonaro Etc so we are
starting to get uh news from Germany and
it's actually looking very very
interesting for social democracy German
social Democrats beat conservatives in
vote to decide merkel's successor social
Democrats SPD ahead in projected results
spd's Schultz claims clear mandate for
pragmatic government but conservative
lachet also vows to seek Coalition as I
mentioned Chancellor Chancellor Angela
Merkel not seeking a fifth term
Germany's this is from Reuters Germany's
social Democrats now narrowly won
Sunday's national election projected
results showed and claimed a quote clear
mandate to lead a government for the
first time
since 25 2005 and to end 16 years of
conservative-led rule under Angela
Merkel now I wouldn't criticize you if
you wrongly thought that Angela Merkel
was a Centrist or on the left there's no
question that compared to American right
wing nuts Merkel seems quite moderate
but by European standards by German
standards Merkel was and is a
conservative and this would be a decided
shift the center-left social Democrats
were on track for 26 percent of the vote
ahead of the 24 and a half percent for
merkel's
cdu-csu conservative block both groups
believe they could lead the next
government
with neither major block commanding a
majority and both reluctant to repeat
their awkward Grand Coalition of the
past four years the most likely outcome
is a three-way Alliance led by either
the social Democrats or merkel's
conservative so we don't yet know the
answers to who will actually be
um uh in charge there agreeing a new
Coalition could take months and will
likely involve the smaller greens and
liberal free Democrats social Democrats
Chancellor candidate Olaf Schultz says
we are ahead in all the surveys now
adding it is an encouraging message and
a clear mandate to make sure that we get
a good pragmatic government for Germany
the spd's rise Heralds a swing left for
Germany and marks a comeback for the
party which has recovered some 10 points
in support in just three months to
improve on its 20 and a half percent
from the 2017 election we don't yet know
what this portends bigger picture for
Europe we we just don't but if we are
hoping that the authoritarian right-wing
slide of the 2012 to 2018 and 19 phase
is going to be pulled back against that
we're going to go back in the opposite
direction certainly this is
something of an auspicious sign now
whether other countries go in the same
direction and whether there will be any
actual progress made in Germany if
indeed Olaf Schultz ends up being the
chancellor very very much remains to be
seen but what we're hoping for and again
we're putting these things together
without actually knowing whether they
are related as part of some bigger
package of change if we continue to see
these humiliations in the U.S for the
right the humiliation in California with
the recall
uh Trump regularly being humiliated you
know we we've been talking about these
things if we start to see this push in
the other direction uh and we also start
to see a rejection of the rising
far-right nationalism uh in Europe of
which Merkel was not a part but still
going Merkel to social Democrats would
be a good sign we may enter what some
have been hoping to be a new Progressive
Era 100 years later remember the
Progressive Era in the United States
started at the very end of the 19th
century and went into the 20s we've
talked about that really important
historical period before and of course
our My Hope as a Social Democrat is that
we would be soon entering a new
Progressive Era could all of these
little data points be starting to signal
in that direction uh maybe maybe remains
to be seen one other article I wanted to
look at CNN reporting SPD narrowly wins
German election against Merkel CDU but
uncertainty remains over left uh over
next leader Germany's left-leaning SPD
will begin negotiations to form a ruling
Coalition after preliminary results
showed the party narrowly winning the
largest share of parliamentary seats
following Sunday's federal election with
all 299 of the electoral districts
reporting
spd-125.7 percent of the vote beating
out the Christian Democratic Union the
Centrist right conservative party of
outgoing Chancellor Angela Merkel which
posted record losses by taking just 24.1
percent but uncertainty over who the
next leader will be one other thought on
Merkel
um again because so many see her as
basically Center left
in the U.S we're so used to seeing
these right Wingers be anti-science
coming from the world of business or law
being governing very much with their
religion in play what I think may be led
some Americans to see Merkel as more
Center left is that her background as a
scientist and her relatively consistent
record of keeping religion out of
governance to some degree although we
could debate that it doesn't feel like
the right winger-ism that we've become
accustomed to in the United States
um and so that's why relative you know
you look at someone like Louie Gomer you
know or Marjorie Taylor green and then
you see Merkel Merkel seems left wing
compared to them I understand that but
Merkel part of the CDU certainly no uh
not not a left-wing party good signs
from these early results in Germany
we're going to continue following what
sort of Coalition gets put together and
also whether this is a sign of things to
come in other European countries one of
our sponsors is Magic spoon breakfast
cereal sweetened tasty like the cereals
I loved as a kid but without the sugar
or the carbs every serving of magic
spoon has zero grams of sugar only four
net carbs 140 calories and packed with
13 grams of protein perfect if you're
doing keto perfect if you're doing low
carb great if you're just trying to
reduce your excess sugar intake and
because it's packed with protein it's
great before or after a workout magic
spoon flavors include cocoa fruity
frosted peanut butter blueberry and
cinnamon They're bringing back cookies
and cream They're bringing back Maple
waffle you can build your own variety
box and try them all magic spoon is so
confident in the product if you don't
love it as much as I do they will refund
your money no questions asked go to
magicspoon.com Pacman the link is
underneath this video and you'll get
five dollars off when you use the promo
code Pacman at checkout